- [Reporter] Chinese fighter jets
carried out simulated attacks
as they flew near Taiwan's airspace,
warships sailed close to
the island's military bases
and major ports, and
long range rockets flew
in the direction of the
self-ruled democracy.
All this was part of war games
following House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi's visit to Taipei.
To understand what China's army is doing,
military analysts have
been looking at footage
from state media and mapping the locations
where the drills have taken place.
Beijing sees Taiwan as
part of its own territory,
and with these military drills,
it's showing how it would
seek to isolate the island
in the event of a conflict.
These are six zones
where the Chinese People's Liberation Army
has been holding its
exercises in recent days.
- China appears to be
practicing its ability
to enforce a blockade in
Taiwan by putting its ships
and planes basically in a
big circle around Taiwan.
- [Reporter] During the drills,
China showed that different
branches of its army
can work in sync.
- China's clearly trying to show
that it can operate in
various regions around Taiwan.
It can coordinate that large military
across the seas and the
air and with its missiles
and its intelligence
gathering its communication,
its reconnaissance.
- [Reporter] But the drills also showed
that Beijing's military has limitations.
Military analysts say that
China appears to lack the assets
to impose a total blockade of the island,
so instead, it seems to be preparing
for a sort of quarantine around Taiwan.
- A mini blockade of
Taiwan, cutting off aspects
of its connections with
the rest of the world,
allowing Taiwan to import food
but not allowing it to
bring in other materials;
for instance, oil.
- [Reporter] Looking closer
at where some of the zones were set up
shows how China could
choke off the island.
This zone located north of Taiwan
is just some 30 miles away from Taipei,
which is home to the island's
busiest international airport.
And this southwest zone
is near Taiwan's most
important commercial port.
And then there's the Taiwan Strait,
one of the busiest trade
routes in the world.
The proximity of the action
to key shipping routes in the region
triggered the delays of
some commercial flights
and shipments, demonstrating the pain
China could also inflict
on world commerce.
- This is a very active area
for shipping, connecting Korea
and Japan with the oil
markets of the Middle East,
connecting the semiconductor industry
with the rest of the world.
- [Reporter] The drills also took place
in parts of Japan's
exclusive economic zone,
an area of the sea that
gives sovereign states
the rights to exploit and
control marine resources.
Japan's defense minister says
some of China's missiles landed there.
- If there is a Chinese
live-fire exercise in those seas,
commercial ships will be deterred
and that will certainly
collapse trade in that area.
- [Reporter] The Chinese military said
it would continue the drills around Taiwan
beyond the initially announced four days.
So as tensions continue to mount,
the question is whether these exercises
would escalate larger military
activity in the region.
- Any sustained effort like we've seen
with these exercises
is clearly gonna result
in more military activity by
the US, possibly by Japan,
and other powers in the region.
(soft tense music)